you guys you have to check out this  incredible video from lake powell  yesterday look at that  uh-huh oh yeah oh look at whoa whoa whoa  whoa yeah look at that brian look at  this  mila and steve cater they were boating  when they saw a few rocks falling then  bam  section of the rock collapsed into the  water  the couple says the video didn't give  the title wave that followed any justice  we'll show it to you again i'm sure wow  on facebook mila writes as if the  channel wasn't rough enough throw on a  rock slide hold on to your shorts can  you can you imagine  if they were pulling somebody on on you  know  exactly  right that's kind of rushing them like a  movie  that's incredible that's like go go go  go go go go faster and faster must go  faster yeah  got brian up brian was watching over  there actually got it from a seat to go  see the coffee all over  it was worth it